is it cool enough for us to work it oh yeah it takes like a hot second for me to
even appear like what I guys guys I killed my broadcast room you what you killed
your broadcast room right now suddenly like stop streaming and then my my
power wash simulator okay I'm live I'm live I'm live I'm live I'm live I'm also
live my chat is laughing at us chat we're so so hello everybody oh god it's been
awful how many wheeler members do you need to do a collab to properly merci
will I make you in your room yay you might need another round I'm just eating
arrows college a live in life so many aritos I want to myself some tea while
we're waiting like I'm busy we'll keep you fuck this frame I'm gonna go make
some tea guys we have been at this for 26 minutes we were on power washer for one
hour and every time we went past four of the girls connecting the the connection
started timing out for some reason but if for some reason in power washer if you
haven't played the entire campaign it doesn't allow you to have six persons in
your lobby and I'm the only one with a finished save file and it was too late
like it's ship all the like code and send on on your stream yeah and so
basically she be rescued she be was like right I'll set this one out you guys just
do it and really know we can't do it the whole point of this is that we're all
together in this so then we're like right who's got g-mod right I don't have it right
who's got rough right I don't have it right who's got this game I don't have it
I was trying my best TV was like going through the list she was flicking them
pages like next page next page next next game okay that won't work literally okay
sure all right we'll do jackpawks and then wait that requires us to screen
record this court I'm like we can't have that we see outrageous things in the
discord we don't even have a HR department so we can't share so then
Garthik phone which I've never played before is coming in clutch right now
Emmys currently making a cup of tea Merci is just getting a room set up for
her because she accidentally nuked her vod of her the collapse dream of any
worse so yeah I think that's like pretty on character yeah insert that meme and
put all of her hairs on it oh aren't VTubers cute when they're almost hmm
or a little that's all I'm gonna say well you guys can finish the sentence
after that but that was okay the hair I remember I was like okay I'm gonna be
honest when they when the harem told me they were called here I read as Haram
and I was like that makes no sense for she be scared I did too I was like what I
have a harem yeah so many people that are my little you know play things and
clients and that they're my harem and that's hair which is a rabbit but it's
not a rabbit hair and rabbit are different but you know what I mean it's a
good fun it's a pun exactly and they're also called Harleys the individuals are
Harleys or Harleys I thought you said Harleys they're Harleys some of them
aren't I can tell you that
Marysse you could do you still have that thumbnail Marysse?
Are we done now?
I got a T.
Almost done me?
I'm back with T.
Marysse if you still have that thumbnail if you just
What's going on?
Is she gonna throw up on stream?
No please no
Yeah it should default to that if you just change to the thumbnail and pick our take
photo
She'll tell herself to stream
What if this is a harem?
I'm sorry I cannot read them
Chad tell me how's everyone's body?
My goodness gracious
What are they doing now?
Yeah, how's the volume?
I feel like yeah, it's my volume. Okay, can you hear everyone else?
Who said the Harleys are waxed in my chat?
The Harleys are waxed
I need them to be clean and proper
Volume good?
I see it I see it
Okay, okay, okay, that's good
How do I change the
garlic phone?
On my big broadcast on OBS
I was doing so bad
They called, we have the column
Virginia thank you for the 10 members
I have the 10 gifts
Don't gift right now
This is off
Any gift
Any gifters
At 2 o'clock
Yeah, any gifters for my non monetize
Yes, we were jealous
Oh no, she Viennese aren't monetized yet
Oh my god, I'm muted
I was muted the entire time
Oh my god
I can hear you
We heard you
I don't know what is happening
I'm so over it
What is this?
What is this dream?
This is awful
This is a fever dream guys
This is a fever
We're all in bed
I don't have a garlic phone thing
Hold on
I guess I should change my stuff now
What? Why do we need to change?
No, you don't have to change anything
As long as you're on stream, you can change it after stream
No one gives a shit when the stream is called
As long as we're online right now
Okay, okay
I'm just doing it because we're all
I'm sitting here
The girls are running around
It'll be fine
We're good
We're gonna have a great time
We think the world is gonna end
Don't forget to like and subscribe
On this stream if you're enjoying
Your experience as a viewer
Smash that bell
To get notifications of when we go live
Smash that bell to get smashed
Yeah
With alcohol or something
I am
I can't help myself
I love you
She loves smashing
She just says smashing
And that's it
She loves smashing
Are we here?
No
I'm barely here
I'm sorry for the mess
We're good?
Yeah, we're here
She's talking to her chat
Blah blah blah
We, a viewer, have done the holistic approach
Where none of us will mute
You're just gonna hear everything
All at once
Yeah, that's how we're all
Just as a reminder
All donations, memberships
Or super chats will be addressed
At the end of the stream
There's an absolute cluster
Buck of all six of us together
But yes
The whole premise of the power washer
Was I was gonna do a gag and be like
Oh, Viola isn't doing so well
We might go bust
So everyone put a bikini on and get clean in
Well, that idea is out the window now
So instead we're playing Gartik Phone
I've never played it personally
She'd be
Suggesting it and her word is
Law, so let's just
Ah, yes
I'm taking over the company
I am the shadow CEO
Okay, do you guys want to start?
You ready?
Let's do it
Three, two, one
Let's go
I know cheating
So chat, don't fucking cheat
Don't fucking do it, I swear to God
I'll beat your ass
How long do I have to do the sentence?
I don't know
Help me out
These lines don't give out
Wait until it's over
This is our secret
Oh wait
I don't think they'll actually know what that is
So let me change it
What's wrong?
We don't have any time
I see
We have to draw these now
We have to draw this
Oh my God
I'm drawing this
I can't see
This is so bad
Oh no
Nothing
Wait
Smell a smaller sheet
Oh no, why are you
Why are you drawing this?
I don't even know what's happening
I can't see anything
Why are you guys screaming?
Oh my God
How much time is left
Why is it left on my God?
The top right corner is the indicator
Not the shading
I'm an artist
I wish I brought my drawing tablet out
An artist
Oh yeah, wait
All you can fucking draw about me
No, we're using our moses
I can look up with the logo
We need to do a witness time
Oh
What the fuck am I doing
What is this shit
I should whip out my drawing tablet
for this
Actually it's better with a mouse
Better with a mouse
No, it's better with a mouse
It looks like hot garden
It looks great
It's like a fucking cave
I think I'm done
Would you?
I'm done
What's that say
Can't tell you
These are items
Okay, that's all I'm saying
I fucking
100% wood
Why not
We need to put the chat logs in quick
These are the chat logs
Oh good answer
Chat logs?
You guys aren't ready for mine
Let's put a bit of detail
We need some wood detail
Americans always have like an eagle
Freak
You're trying to describe it
What is this
What the fuck
Ew
Oh shit
Oh
There we go
What do you think
Julie
Oh no
Bro
I
I was supposed to
My gen mates are wild
Fuck
Oh my god
I don't know what he looks like
Oh god
Hold on
She be sent so far away
Cause I don't know what my mic
Oh right
I don't know what Thornberry looks like
Oh no
I had to look it up
I'm just going for it
Right
What do I look like
Oh wait
I don't look like that
Sugar
Don't question
They can't curve
Bunches
Don't question this
What the fuck
How do you draw
I don't know
Oh my
Perfect
Oh I don't know how to draw
I don't know how to draw anymore
That's great
That's pretty good right
They agree with me
Oh my god
This is something
Hold on
Oh shit
Ginger in it
Sweet
I don't know what
This is awful
I'm sorry
This is
I don't know
Let's draw some hair
Oh my god
Oh my goodness
Draw his thorn
His nose
Just google a picture
I'm still late
The phone rang
That is very nice thank you
I'm glad you agree to it
My little leaflings are saying I'm a true artist
Your hair is not orange
Is it?
Oh my god
Wait I'm ginger
Are you blonde
Your hair is orange
I thought I was blonde
This whole time
I've been drawing myself
What the fuck are you looking at
I'm sorry
In my image
What does that even say
May I
Eat
Meow
Oh meow
Oh my god
Meow
Which one of you speaks Spanish
Cause I
Oh lord
What
Oh
How am I supposed to draw that
Oh my god
Did we even have
What do I look like
Oh wait I can't even draw the fucking toilet
Alright hold on
What do I even look like
Oh
This is terrible
This is so hard with a mouse
Um
I love this shit
It's so fucking cursed
Hits his armpits
We're grabbing onto the ground
We're holding onto your life
Right armpits
So
I don't know
Oh my god
Cause
Cause none of you guys know like some English phrases
Or some like
Jokey phrases so I can already
Like what I'm hearing is that a lot of you guys are misinterpreting
What I've written and it's very funny
It's going all over his back
It's not looking good
Edit
How do you draw an angry mouse
Like a
Oh there we go
And then
And we need
We need to draw
Weeds of sweat
This is amazing
What does the Walmart logo look like
What
Your armpits has become sentience
Walmart
I'm not even going to explain to Mercy
Are you going to call it toilet?
Oh wait
Don't do toilet
I see
It makes it worse
Oh my god
I think that works out
I can't wait to see everyone
All according
Now we'll get to see everything
There's going to be no voice over
And then we'll do
Beginning from the end
Okay
So
So I said
I see with Nigel Thornberry's face
Saying smashing
And Mercy's
I see
My favorite mood
Mashery
Mash
Scrum
This is over
Oh my god
Okay
Go ahead
Oh no
Oh boy
Your honor
She wanted it
Oh my god
She said it's going to jail for the crabs
You know date look
Oh no
Okay
Oh my god
I love it
It actually worked out
Why is your OG Santa such a fat cock?
Yeah
Because he loves me
And his dick grows thick
With all the love you have for me
They grew sick of times that day
All right
Sestrani's
I'm sorry
Oh my god
Mercy's cheesy
Festival in Feet
Oh no
I feel like her feet is actual cheese
I know
I like that
Stinky Pete's
But like
And then she drew
Pits
Oh my god
Oh my god that's too good
She's cutting out
She's screaming so loud
That's her
Okay
Very good artist
Thank you
What does that even mean?
When your job is a poo
So when your poo hits your prostate
On the way out it feels good
Oh my god
What is this?
Is Amy sucking?
Amy suckers on them hot toes
Oh wait, is she giving a blowjob?
That's what it looks like
Mercy what did you draw?
What does it look like to me?
Oh my god
Really?
I love the drool
This is so fucking good
The drool is so good
Oh boy
We are
Over some pie
Okay
That was pretty good
That's really cute toilets
That's not a cat
Meow
Meow winky face
Okay it's a winky face
I was like what is meowers
I was like no one speaks Spanish
I didn't hire anyone to speak Spanish
Neato
That's good
I love that
Okay this makes sense
This makes sense of what
on earth we were drawing
Because I was to check out
And like that's items on the shelves
I worked really hard
I didn't get that
Oh this is a good diaper
I see understood me
I love the details
Take the magic
Honestly
Why is it coming out of his back
It's fighting for his life
It's going everywhere
It's like air is back
I can't
I had toilet stole cap
Because that's all I see about
When I like see American memes
They're like oh the toilet stole
The toilet gap is so big
You can literally look at people's eyes
Is it not like that
It's a different version
We have them closed
Because you know it's a private time
And you're very vulnerable taking a big job
So yeah it's actually closed everywhere
Else in the planet
You're so lucky
I had people peeking at me
In high school through the stalls
Me too
Oh no it didn't
Is there a check
Is there a DC check
Do you need to reload that
It's gonna
Do it on its own usually
No I'm gone
The link should be in the discord
Don't show your fucking screen on the discord
Don't
Do that
Of our naughty photos
We just sent to each other
It's mostly memes
Any memers
I mean to be fair we did share
Some naughty photos
We did share some
Lucky nudes of ours
They've seen my TTs
So uh
I started roleplaying as the girls with my nudes
So I was like this is what Ibi would do
This is what Acey would do
This discord is so chaotic
Okay real though
But also I did snort out my T
It like went down the wrong hole
And went up my nose
Wow mercy I hear snort and
T
This is what galley offers
A stosterone
Is this better
Yeah
Are you in game
I pushed it
That's what it's like so in my ears
I'm getting a little deep
Getting another hard beat right now
Every time she talks
Have a turn
News or eye round news
What do you think
Oopsy
I feel like Azura could do a really good Jennifer Coolidge impression
Me too
Jennifer Coolidge
Do do do do
I don't know
Jennifer Coolidge's impression
Wait you don't know Jennifer Coolidge
Oh Jennifer Coolidge
I
I'm gonna switch
Oh my god
I can't do it
Jennifer Coolidge
You can't go in your gap
For the Rizzler
Why are we opening our gap
Azura
Click that link in the general
Click that link
You can't go in
I can't go in
What is happening
You're making cuts
When you do that Azura
So it just goes
Eww
What's happening
What's happening anymore
It's constantly loading
It's literally
Let me do another
I'm gonna
Will you guys see the discord
If I open it okay you guys can't see it
No
I shouldn't see anything else
I would close the window capture
In the OBS just in case
Yes you can open it
Are we restarting a new lobby
A new lobby
I think we should all invite to this lobby
A bit of all
Why is there two
Are we going to a different room
I don't know
Why is there two
I only see one of you
No on mine
There's
No
Where'd you go
Okay which one should we play
Normal
Which we just did
Knock off, keep yourself focused
Try to replicate the drawings while the clock gets faster
Animation
Create an animation in a collaborative way
Icebreaker, play with a sentence
Ask questions and have fun with others drawings
Exquisite co-ops
Create surrealist characters connected by the top of the drawings
Don't know what that means
Hold on
Burt friends have a good time with that
Compliment, complete the sketch
Start with basic lines and see other players' interpretations
Masterpiece, create a piece of art
Play in a single turn with no time limit
I feel like story would be funny
Let's try a previous sentence
Story, story, story
Do you want to do a story
Let's try a story
What are you doing
Sorry
Oh
Wait do I have to write a full story
Or just a sentence
Just a sentence
Okay
Oh
Do you like write the whole story
Or no
You have really limited characters
I don't know it
No
What did you do
There's time
15 seconds love
I wanted to write more
I can only write one sentence
Shit
I feel like I should be drunk
We are not beating the caca
No we're not
What the fuck is happening
Oh they're going to know this is me spelling it
Because I didn't use that Z
Don't know
I'm just going to leave it like that
Yep
I'm sending it
I'm not even spell checking
The lack of spell check is good
Fuck it
I'm bad at stories
What is this
Why
It's over
Oh
Oh the sentence is so small
Like I want to give a bit more
Me too
But it's too short
I think it gets shorter over time
I want to be like bi-
Well I could have write until
Fuck
What
You're sleeping
Wow
Let's see
Oh no
Fuck
Fuck I'm so bad
It's funny because
I hate this I can't think of anything
The reeflings, the snowberries, the snippets
The pin pals
The bleedin' hearts
And the harem all get to see this unfold
And we're all just tapin' like
Ugh
Fuck it
Oh you
Wait is that the fucking
You watch fucking
Bank theory
Wait that's a nice spell
Paris
Fuck
Give me more
I need more letters
I need more like I can't
I don't know why they didn't
Go ahead and play this
To help me spend song lyrics
They jerk so hard mother fuckers want to find me
That sounds like she me
No
They jerk so hard mother fuckers want to find me
Wait
This
This agency
We can just
I spelled it wrong but that's the point
I hate that's like
They don't give you enough to write
Yeah there's no story
Not enough
Fuck off
Okay let's see what's happening
So how about everybody
Read their own story like
Okay
Okay I go first
In a galaxy far far away
There was a goat with big titties
She had so much milkers
It started raining milk
Azera then went home
To make an empire bane milk daily
It was so successful
The neighboring kingdoms became jealous
They also
Wanted some of the juicy
Ew cooties
We're not good
Okay long time ago
In a kingdom called far away
There was a boy by princess
Who was trying to fit into
Their love was stronger than any foreign addiction
They couldn't stop jerking
I'm so sorry I'm jerking
They jerk so hard mother fuckers want to find me
They say it's just a jerk
I was like this agency
Ding ding
It was supposed to be the song like ding ding
I was so hard
I was in Paris
There was a beach of agency
That was lit
They opened
And controlled the urges
So they danced
The pee pee danced until they kicked
And then finally they peed everywhere
On the floor
The walls, the bed, the kind
We're all filled with piss everywhere
But he loved it
The fact that we're going to piss
Prompt before AC came out with that
Let's just say there wasn't any AC
Because of the board
AC came out of the board
I'm sorry
This is so good
Okay
Once upon a time there were whores
They were the elitist of whores
They had wild whores
They had all these really cute cowgirls
They had so cute
So fuzzy
So pussy warm
Thanks
You're more like bang bang your mama
Keep my mom out of your home now
I'm sorry
10 out of 10
That's the time they were like this
Oh no
Oh shit
I know you guys know why I write the scripts in v-alert
Why am I?
I think we can deserve a road of each other
She was sad because she realized she didn't have the frosting
Why do I keep talking about shit all the time?
She became sheep green tentacles
Fuck no
So no, I didn't want to be pregnant by Sonic
Azura, do you have a mic filter on? I can never hear you
Who's turning that mic?
Get that steel seat out
See that steel steering
No it's not
Don't have a filter on
There's no filter on?
What is happening?
Your steel series filter
I don't have a filter
Don't have one on
What is happening?
Can't wait for the void if they survive
They'll be fine
Do you want to try another one?
Another, another, another
Another one
Please, please, no more shit
No more shit and piss
No more shit, stop
No promises
I didn't even do what you said
It was you guys
Can we do a compliment?
We have promised one
Compliment
All the actions are a mystery
Drawings and sentences are hidden during this
You can't hear mercy, mercy test
Mercy test?
Sorry, I was muting because I was coughing
Okay, mercy test complete
Do you want to do a compliment?
What is that?
We draw on each other's drawings
We should try that
I think that would be fun
Can't wait to draw so much piss
That's the basic lines
Start sketch some basic lines
Okay
We'll do this
I'm just going to draw a bunch of dicks
Are you so cute?
What the fuck
You know exactly what you did
And no, I don't have the strength to resist
What's going on?
I got it, I can make this
I can salvage this
This is the back legs of it
And then this is its huge
Mokers
And then this
This is its legs
There you go
Only a few more left
Uh huh
You're so dirty
Don't be so dirty minded
Honestly
I'll get the girl to tell you off
If you don't behave
You guys don't have innocent eyes anymore
What
Cute
Rude to me
Wait
Am I supposed to finish this off?
Are we supposed to finish it all?
I think so because it's given us tons of time
Hold on
Oh, okay
I fixed it
A big fish up bro
Oh my god, I've just made Chibi
What the hell
I heard my name
Oh wait, that's a thing
Oh no, that looks like
Dang it
Let's just do that
There you go
I saved it
Babe, it gave you a lot more time
Yeah, you're to finish it
Ah, you need to finish
Okay, I'm fucking stupid
Okay
So Am I, don't worry
I saved it
Let me do it
Let's put some nice shading in
To make this look extra beautiful
Wow
Let's put lipstick on
Yeah
So beautiful
I saved it
They pranked me
I think this is the best time
Who drew a pair of hairy ball sacks?
Come on
What?
What are we supposed to do with this?
She's supposed to add the shaft
Oh, I really know what I want to do
But I know I shouldn't do it
Because we're on YouTube
I'm fixing this
Oh no
I can't
One thing
This is amazing
Oh wait, maybe, hold on
I got it
Fuck, how do I go back
The snow bears
They've got a big head
Wow
I've drawn them too
This is so fucking good
Let's fucking go
I'm trying so hard right now
I can't even think of anything to say
Oh my gosh
Imagination
There you go
Look at you all
I'm so proud of you
Your laugh is so cute
Thank you
I love you so much
I just think I did mine really well
Yeah, it's a water bottle
That's the best I got
I saved the pair of ball sacks
Did you make it into a dog or something?
No
It just works
Can you
Tenpais, can you do better? Shut the fuck up
I love when you do that
Shut the fuck up
Oh my god
What is this?
Wow
You're asking me not to draw a vagina with those
Oh my god
What do I do?
How am I supposed to do with this?
How am I supposed to do this?
How do I save this?
I need to do this all for memory
I won't draw that
Oh my god
I just realized
I'll draw this instead
You thought women were less immature than men?
You're wrong
I wasn't going to draw a coochie
or a woman giving birth
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing
I literally don't know what the fuck
I'm doing right now
Wait hold on
Oh my god
I have time
Can you guess who it is now?
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing
Fuck
Be like ones
Pen pals
Quick quick quick quick
I'm running out of time
Oh my god
This is okay
And then volcano
These are like ones
Oh oh oh
I'm trying I'm trying I'm trying
I got it I got it
I don't know
Oh god
Reflex how could I forget your fucking
I
I saved it
I think I did a good job
This is the best I got I ain't got none other than me
Why do I feel like
This is really bad this happened
This is a really specific reference
And I don't know if anyone can
I get it but
There used to be a flash game
Where your guy was on like a snowboard
I love that game
I know what you're talking about
Someone literally just drawn that
Literally this is perfect
That's it that's my drawing
Someone says lane rider
Oh is that what it's called?
What
What is bear pants
Oh
Is it panties
I was so confused
I saw people were asking me to draw
Bear wearing underwear
I was like what the fuck is wrong with you guys
Newsy pants
I remember fancy pants
Cause he had big old
Pants that were
Fence
Why not
And now is not the time
To pop a bomb in my lap
Cause he blundered at me though
You know the story
I might make that up
Right hydration check
Girlies I don't want your boyfriend dying
Okay
You know the story
Some water
Pants
He's guggling my balls sorry
He had no hair color but his pants were yellow
Let me do that for you
Do you have a beard? I don't know
I do something
Needs hip
Yeah you're right I don't really know how to do that though
Can I zoom in
No
Yeah
It's like a beer braid
Braid is pants though
Stop
Yeah
No fuck I didn't mean to add that
Who drew ball sacks everywhere
It's not you sheebie
No I didn't draw a ball sack
Oh
I got it
Who's whispering
What
Zura's whispering some like
Evil incantations to us
See it's great
It was definitely a Zura that drew the ball sack 100%
I feel like this is a lie
No I didn't draw it
I'm really drawing over it right now
If you guys didn't know
Zura's ears actually have golden
Little jewelry on the end of them
Oh
This is icy
Pimped out with jewelry but it's like
Not about anything
Here you go
Going for her first bike ride
Right
Isn't cheating to a race? Ah fuck it is
Okay
Isn't it cute
So if you didn't know
When a women
When a women like taste chat
Oh my god
It goes through the fabric
Okay so they'll be like
Oji-san is so happy for her
I know this isn't a Zura
It's cold
That looks terrible get rid of that
Oh my god you can't just control Z
What's wrong with my life
I was trying to talk about lactation
Duh
This is yeah it was right before she said
Chocolate that was correct
Milk
So painful
That's the timer
Oh
I thought you were drawing a cute bunny face
Nah they have some titties mate
It's all I can see
I can't see
I have saved
I have single handedly saved the stream probably
We'll do that
This is supposed to be the liquid
The liquid
Wait I just know I have to draw my own drawing
But that's cheating
I know what I wanted to draw
That's nothing
Fine
I don't even know what to draw for my own drawing
I started it and I'm gonna finish it
It's me
Fucking mental
I don't know
I'm already pissed
It's the odd
Okay
I would talk
But it takes too much brain power
To do this
I don't know
My cats are fighting
Stop
This is a net
I don't know
What
It's a pretty good net
Hold on
How do you spell squelch
Squelch?
Yeah
Is it the Amazon?
Oh my god
Is it the reverse Amazon position
When the girls...
What are you drawing?
Reverse Amazon
Yeah
That's definitely what she's talking about
Can they break it?
Oh wait
I need to click them
Oh boy
Alright
Does anybody need to take a quick break
Before
I'm ready
Let's go
Let's do this
That was yours
Okay
That's really cute
What the hell
Oh my god
What
Okay
I tried drawing
Is it Orser's hand?
Yeah
Oh that's so good
What do you mean you're a bad artist
That's a very good little bear
Yeah that's so cute
Look at how cute your handwriting is
He got a photo under the blanket and everything
Oh yeah
Oh it's the artist
Okay
What else could I draw for this
Oh that's cute and awesome
I like it
I did a desert
There's no job open now
Wait
Oh my god
I saved them
I lied
If I don't see a snail
What pretty thing is there
Oh shit
Oh my god
That's so cute
You guys are on the same page
It is
I love replays
Oh my god that's so cute
Okay you were the one that drew that
Yeah that was cute
That's so cute
Aww
I drew me and the boys
That's so cute
Oh
Hey baby
Literally me
That's me
That's a pretty pretty
I see
Oh my god
These are so bad
I can't show that
I see
What do you mean the boys
Oh okay okay
That's so cute
Why the mono bros
Wait
What are you guys
I drew this little game
I was like oh this is like later
I like the game
That's creative
Yeah that's good
Aww
That's so cute
That's me
Uh oh
And me
Aww that's cute
That's so cute
I told you
I told you it was Zera
Lama Chewbuffer Gentoo
Um
I was like that's a good one
And then I saw the thing and went
Aww
That's cute Mercy
Wait I see he's learning how to ride a bike
Okay
Oh that was good
That was so fucking good
That was good
How are we on time and stuff
Help
Let's go breathe
Oh no
This is what is like to be in VLR
It's not like I'm giving birth
I want to figure out what ice biker is
Ice biker is kinda boring
Okay hold on I'll stop it
I'll cancel it
Wait
Ice biker is boring
Yeah it's boring
Can I cancel it
If you want
How do I cancel it
Wait are we doing this or are we cancelling it
I don't know
I cancel it
What is happening
Oh there's a fucking ad
I'm just making another room
Okay
Where is my character
That you guys can see
Jon Snow and Sansa Star
Jon Snow
Wait no just put me back in
They still advertise
Wait
Put me in the same lobby
Do you guys want to make it
Wait what is happening
I don't know what is happening
Somebody else make a lobby
It's not the greatest but we can just play it
No somebody else make a lobby
I'm confused
Do we have a new lobby or not
Somebody else make it because
I made a new one I was trying to make a new one
Just threw me back in it
Everyone hate the asset
Hate the game, the garlic phone window
Okay hate it first
And then someone make a new one
I can't make it because of my connections dog
I'll do it
See Emmy proven what big girl she is
That was so fucking weird I'm sorry
I'm so fucking creepy
I'm so sorry
Sorry
It's so chaotic
I don't know why there's two of me on screen
When I hate up
I hate up
Get a thick phone
Get a thick
Emmy just put up a new one
Show us a link in the discord
I sent it
Okay
Understood
So yes sir
Let me open the link
Oh there we go nice and easy
I've got a pasha
Okay is everyone here
I'm here
Yeah we're here
Okay which one do you want to play
Okay
I don't know
Knock off is fun
Because it's like super
Try to replicate the drawing
Oh yeah do knock off
Do knock off that looks good
Okay
Because you make it pretty drawing and then
It becomes hell
Wait why are we supposed to draw
Anything you want
Anything
I'm going to draw
Maybe not anything for you
No not shit
Give us something I'm being put on the spot
My main is going blank
Yeah I'm going to draw
Oh wait yeah you're good
Cheebie we can't see
I'll draw
I'm taking off the blindfold you're fine now
I'll draw Cheebie
Should we all just like draw somebody
Oh
No I'm joking I'm joking
I was like oh I'm kind of locked in
Sorry sorry I've decided to draw
One of us
I don't know what to draw
Guys give me an idea
Don't put me on the spot
Don't put me on the spot I don't know
I don't even know what to draw
Put me on the G spot
Oh one of you guys so I'm going to choose
On the spot
You want me to draw that
Oh this is terrible on a mouse
That one's actually funny
How much time do we have
Can I draw the whole gang again
I'll make sure
You have quite a bit of time with this one
Okay hold on
What the fuck is going on
Oh that's not how you draw the whole gang
Oh no
Oh
How the fuck do you draw something
Sitting down oh my god I'm having a stroke
I'm not the good king
What on earth
There's a good client
I'm supposed to be a snow fairy
I'm going to get beaten up by AC
After this oh my god
Oh my god what what
I want to draw harmony I want to draw unity
Perfect
I can't draw like this
Wait it has kind of like
Who's next
We need to draw the devilish
Fuck this is hard cause like
I don't know what to fucking draw
Get creative nerds
Geez it's not that
It's not that hard you can do
Okay Miss Artist
Okay
Eventually
Amy's like I'm just going to draw myself casual
And it comes out with like this fucking
Banger of a commission
It would probably cost like 500 dollars to do
And she like bangs it out
And I'm like oh my god
I'm going to make a vtuber model
He he
Wish I could
Wish I had a finger
Nerval talent
Speaking of that
They were like thank you for not
Tying down your talents
To the designs that you assign them
And they can be more themselves and I'm like
Yeah well why would I do that
I was like
I don't know why I feel like it's such a basic things
What the fuck do I need to draw next
A bleeding heart
Yeah we're more like
Building upon the characters
Rather than
Changing everything
Cause um
Right at the vtuber
They were like the only thing that would have been better
Is if you let them design
Their models like from the start
I'm like bro it took me a fucking year to get here
Like oh my god give me like a fucking
It takes forever
To
Draw and rig a vtuber model
Yeah
You can ask Amy she knows how to
She knows how to do it
It's a lot of work
Oh my god
Yeah there's only a select few corpos that will
Let you do that
Oh shit
Man this is rough
Usually ones that have like artists in house as well
Ahh
Yeah we don't
This is so bad
Most companies
If not all of them
Say for you
Will have pre
Pre-made
It's actually standard for people to choose
Yeah it's really not
You
That's why it's usually they cast for the roles
You have to fit the
Character they're looking for
Oh oh oh
It's magic
Oh oh
You know
Oh
What is this
Are we ready? Yeah, I'm ready
Just draw it your way. Yeah, that's the fun part. Yeah
I've already forgot which position
Oh
Sorry, we flinch honestly, I would talk more but this takes so much brainpower to do
Reading chat I'm reading everything, but I'm not responding. I'm so sorry because we everyone's
I'm just really in this
Fucking losing it. Oh
My god, wait
That's far too short, so this is why it's chaotic
Oh my god
Okay
Oh sure, there's like a lot of time we draw this as fast as we can
Can't remember what it looks like
Is there supposed to be someone in a pirate boat by the way, cuz I don't think I saw it
supposed to be a person in it, I don't know
Oh, it's already have
Oh
My god
Okay, okay, okay, we can do this
Do this, okay, okay, okay, okay, let's go. Don't panic
Okay, this is easy. This is easy. This has to be men's this has to be men's
Fucking go
Man this looks like shit
Oh
At least it stayed a cat
Oh they're cute!
It's no face
Oh we're argued in real time
Like egg and faces
At the end of the day, or I'll just stick ring here
Okay, this is good this stage
Oh
She's not in jail she's
There
Peace
Oh
Shooting her
What have we not done
All the actions are mystery drawing and sentences are hitting during the game
I've never done that one before
Okay, we'll try we're doing secret right last room boys last room. Okay. Okay. Okay. Um
Oh, shit. Oh what I can't see what I'm writing
How do I just know what I'm writing?
Wait what?
Huh
Yeah, oh no, wait you run it with freaking words. Oh bro. I can't erase my
I don't know
It just appears. Oh, we can't see what we're drawing
Okay, we'll drop out
Okay
Okay, I don't know I think
I'm gonna just guess
What it is where it is
What the fuck?
Oh, no, no
Uh, I'm gonna try to draw. Why is it so hard to draw with a mouse?
Oh
These are the past can I can I go backwards does it work like that?
Uh, I didn't give you his legs
Oh sugar
Yeah, um
Okay, he's somewhere there
I have no idea
Okay
Okay, that's a lot all wrong
Oh
Oh, I don't know what else to draw that's that's exactly what I drew I think
This is a vain reference. I don't know what the fuck I'm doing
Locked in I locked in did I give
Wait, did I give them bodies? I don't think I gave them bodies. Oh my god. I don't even know where they are
I don't know
I'm taking a shot in the dark
That is gonna be interpreted as
And will I stop the creative flow do you
Wait, oh my god. Who's no emmy emmy's got a hoodie here. Oh sugar. I don't
Fuckin I put juice on her
I don't even know what the fuck I'm doing anymore. I'm fucking dying
What what is this?
What is this
Someone had a stroke whoever drew this one. Hope you're feeling okay. Hope you didn't all right make sure you hydrate
How do I even draw this
This is uh
Mm-hmm
That's the tongue
And then this is literally everyone
me
Okay, then
Fuck am I trying?
I
Need like motion swipes as well
And a little arrow to indicate
Yeah, there we go, I think I drew it correctly
Cute I don't know I just
I
Can't wait to see the end of this
This is a great this will be a great
What's going on the ceiling on each other on the ceiling quick? Oh, I think I just
Oh
I was gonna ride even being
That's why you were humming Indiana Jones. I was like, where did that come from?
I was trying to write cowboy, but I didn't
Oh, that's so adorable
Oh
I can't read oh my face hurts so bad
Hey
Oh
Your mom calling me
My cheeks hurt from
Okay, okay
Oh
Somebody download that one
I got no permission or your sunscreen
Tag yourself, I'm the ropes I'm tying in me to the tracks. Oh my god, right
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna injure the girls to anything more because like we're our faces are ready to fall off after that
Is anyone doing a stream?
Is anyone put um are you doing a straw away as neuro because I'll disappear really bad, right? I'm gonna jump out of the call
If I'm gonna jump out of the call
I know
I
I'm going to jump out of the call and do a little that so then I'll redirect into user. Oh, okay
Okay, I might play do you guys want me I might play some call the lamb
So if you if someone does a pop-up stream just tell me I'll talk to that my refunds for a bit
Thank you so so much all members and dolls for this hilarity that ensued after such a miserable start
It's such a miserable start to power water chat myself from laughing
No, no
Okay
Okay, bye
They are
Okay, wait, I'm so are you guys still streaming? Okay, okay
Mm-hmm. No, Stonny said she was
Mm
I
Can you on
Okay
Hang up and then I'll go to the uh, la la la just chatting and then I'll send I'll I'll check if y'all ready. Okay
Later
Okay, bye. Bye. Bye
Bye
Sorry you couldn't hear them for a little bit I for I for gore
I'm so tired
I only watch 24 minutes of it by laugh so hard. I am literally dead tired from laughing and coughing
Right we wanted to we wanted to play power wash simulator, but we couldn't get everyone to connect it just wasn't working
I don't know
I'm gonna leave that game but you can literally hear my voice is leaving
um
I don't know who to raid
Yeah, I don't
Is um
Is strony playing roblox or is that a roblox ad that's a roblox ad is she talking
I
Guess I'm rest. I will I will
But I wanted to redirect into someone but I don't know who
Strony's pissed and oh
Is mercy still going okay, I'll redirect into strony because I know that strony will
stream
I don't know who's ending, but I know I am
I had so much the fun. Thank you for the peeler stream. You're welcome. I had fun too
I know I didn't know that I was ginger
Didn't know that I was ginger. I thought I was blonde
Maybe I'll make myself more ginger because
I really thought I was just like a really really bright blonde and I was wondering like why is my hair so
Like bright blonde. It's because I'm fucking ginger. What the fuck?
And every time I was drawing myself. I was drawing myself as like a blonde blonde
Because I thought I was supposed to be blonde
I'm ginger
Well
Yeah, it all makes sense now
I probably might change my emo design to look more ginger
Because like ginger people have like reddish hair, don't they?
Strawberry blood. No, no
No, so
It does make sense. I still love you even though you're ginger. Thank you
I still love you too
Even though you're dead
Okay, uh, let me let me
Fuck that's what I wanted. Did I I need to I need to add the redirect
Reddish orange. Yeah, like ginger people have like reddish orange hair
And mine looks really blonde to be ginger. Not shitting on the model artist or anything
Next time look at ginger people though. I know it's hard to look at them because they're so fucking pale, but like
Use your references
You saw me using all my references
During this game. Um, oh, oh Zeriz playing Sturge Valley though
Ginger the whole time
Yeah, it does look really blonde. That's what I'm saying
Um
Right, I'll redirect into Azura. Yeah
Okay, there we go
So
I didn't realize so that that's what I yeah, I didn't realize
Ginger's scary you good. You should be scared of me. I'm scary
girl
You're pissing your pants yet
Yeah, it explains the freckles, but you know
Not not only ginger people have freckles, so I wasn't sure
Um, but yeah, I'll stream tomorrow. I'll start stream around, uh, 12
I don't know how long I'll go probably not too long. Um, we'll see. We'll see
You're not you're not scary. You're an adorable ginger
I'm glad I'm glad you think I'm cute. I sound so fucking gross and snotty right now
It's because my voice has gone from screaming and laughing
Right
Yeah, I'll see you tomorrow. Um, really early in the day. You better be there or else I'm gonna cry. Um
Um, yeah
See you later
Love you
You